time dilation The Fifth Dimension
gravity's ability to transcend time and
space yep if you watched Christopher
Nolan's sci-fi epic Interstellar and
ended up with more questions than
answers you are not alone here are the
most confusing moments of interstellar
explained Professor brand is the father
of astronaut Dr Amelia brand and has
dedicated his entire life and career to
solving the gravity equation once he
passes away murf takes on the
responsibility of searching for the
answer but throughout the m movie it is
never made clear what exactly they have
been after what is apparent is the
purpose once this mysterious equation is
solved humans will be able to use
gravitational anomalies to manipulate
gravity and to safely get everyone off
the planet the snag in the plan is that
the data from inside a black hole is
needed to complete it no one has ever
seen inside a black hole so there was no
way to get the data until Cooper for
obvious reasons the movie couldn't get
into the gritty scientific details of
the fake equation but what is important
to know is that anomalies are crucial to
the solution and a black hole is the
biggest anomaly of all when Coupe goes
inside the black hole Gargantua at the
end of interstellar and transmits that
data to murf she is finally able to
solve the equation and save Humanity the
opening 30 minutes of interstellar are
confusing on the first watch through and
perhaps even after a repeat viewing
during that First Act you might be left
wondering what this whole ghost story
has to do with space travel and saving
the human race well as it turns out
everything by the end of the movie you
will learn that Cooper is the ghost or
gravitational anomaly trying to
communicate with murf through time while
he is in the Tesseract when Coupe is
inside the Tesseract he realizes he can
communicate with young murf via the
bookshelf we see the mirror image of an
earlier scene where the ghost spells out
the word stay through morph code here we
learn that it is actually Cooper trying
to convince himself not to leave murf
behind at this point in the story Cooper
regrets ever leaving and tries to change
the past although it cannot be done
Coupe can travel through the dimension
of time though and he uses the bookshelf
to communicate the solution to Professor
Bran's formula when she visits the house
in the present timeline perhaps the
single most confusing moment of
interstellar is the significance of the
watch that Cooper gives to murf when she
is a child in a moment of anger she
breaks it but it stays in the house for
years when Cooper goes into Gargantua
and winds up in the Tesseract he sends
murf a coded message that solves the
gravity equation he does this by using
gravity which is a force that transcends
time according to the film to move the
hands of the watch and communicate with
murf in morph code by manipulating
gravity he can cause the broken watch to
tick encode and transmit the information
to save Humanity there are many theories
as to how exactly this works because the
film never explains it cleanly since
time isn't passing for Coupe he can
potentially spend as much time as he
wants perhaps even years transmitting
what he needs murf to know considering
all the time she loses while he's away
though perhaps the watch as a medium is
really just a symbol of his urgency to
finish the mission and reunite with his
daughter back in 2014 it wasn't
advertised that Matt Damon would make an
appearance in interstellar so when he
showed up on an icy Planet as the
stranded scientist Dr man Nolan fans
were shocked by the surprise but as
Cooper and man spend more time together
Cooper starts to realize that man is
more than a little shady as it turns out
man has faked the data that indicates
life on the planet is possible if he'
told the truth he would have been left
to die instead he lies and waits in
cryosleep until another NASA team
inevitably shows up to respond to his
signal man's plan is then to hijack the
ship of whoever comes for him and leave
them stranded this selfish Act of
self-preservation very likely could have
ended in man in Eternal cryosleep so why
was that the plan in interstellar man
represents the human drive to stay alive
Don't Judge Me
Cooper you were never tested like I
was human have been
he goes to extremes and would rather
potentially wait in cryosleep for
thousands of years instead of dying his
plan has a major flaw but it is a risk
he's willing to take since the
alternative is freezing to death one of
the most confusing moments of
interstellar has nothing to do with
interdimensional travel or quantum
physics it is instead a choice made by
murf as the film reaches its climax
while riding in the car away from the
childhood home murf jumps out of the
truck and then proceeds to light her
brother Tom's cornfield on fire at this
point in the timeline those crops are
vital to the survival of not just her
family but the entire remainder of the
human race so why is such an extreme
action from a character who genuinely
loves her brother this weird outof
character moment makes more sense when
you realize murf is merely buying time
and using this Scorch toe measure as a
desperate distraction she needs to go
back inside the house to finish what she
started as a child from an earlier scene
we already know that Tom will no longer
listen to murf so she needs to do
something extreme to distract him while
she tries to find the solution to her
equation luckily she does manage to
figure out how to save the planet in
that 15-minute window she's created for
herself otherwise Tom would be Mighty
upset Upon returning to the farm and the
whole family would be much worse off a
major twist in the second half of
interstellar is that the Elder Dr brand
who sends his own granddaughter and
Cooper on the mission knows everyone
still on Earth is doomed to die NASA
first sends the Explorers into space
with a plan A and A Plan B devised by Dr
brand plan a is to find a habitable
planet and then once brand solves his
gravity equation back on Earth send the
planet's remaining population to that
new home however brand actually doesn't
plan on solving the equation and knows
it is going to be Plan B all along each
iteration is an attempt to prove its own
proof it's recursive it's nonsensical in
the case of Plan B Cooper and the others
will find a suitable Habitat to rebuild
Humanity with thousands of Frozen
embryos thus keeping the human race race
alive but dooming Earth bran knows Coupe
will not go through with the mission if
he tells him the truth he can't tell his
daughter for the same reason but on an
even deeper level he can't face telling
her what he has done so he keeps that a
secret until his dying breath when he
finally reveals the Dark Truth to murf
even fans of Nolan's film catalog have
called out Interstellar for being
ridiculous to a fault with certain
conceits one of these moments is the
movie's final twist where Cooper doesn't
just survive a black hole encounter but
finds himself transcending linear time
the scene inside the Tesseract requires
serious suspension of disbelief to make
sense throughout the film Coupe and murf
repeatedly refer to a mysterious they
that they believe to be communicating
with them prompted mostly by The Ghost
and its messages this is the central
mystery that wraps up in the Tesseract
scene where it is revealed that Cooper
is the one communicating with murf
through the bookshelf this scene also
explains what the Tesseract is and who
built it as it turns out they did and
they are humans from an specified number
of generations in the future at that
Untold point in time they have evolved
to be able to exist in the Fifth
Dimension in the Paradox inducing
explanation this future generation
creates the Tesseract that allows Cooper
to navigate five Dimensions thus saving
themselves from the past and ensuring
their own existence the monologue brand
gives near the end of the movie is a
controversial subject to say the least
it gets a lot of hate but Defenders will
rally in droves to tell you it's one of
the most important parts of the movie
and they are right you need to take it
seriously in the infamous speech brand
explains that love is the only thing
that transcends all five Dimensions she
argues that love is something that
exists and is quantifiable which
ultimately ends up being what Cooper
needs to save Earth the only way he is
able to contact murf through the
bookshelf in Gargantua is through their
familial love connection Coupe even
exclaims it's just like Bran's said my
connection with murf it is quantifiable
it's the key in an added layer of
meaning it is also Humanity's love for
each other that inspires them to build
the Tesseract and save the past
generation Interstellar has what many
would consider a happy ending Coupe
makes it back to Earth in time to see
his daughter one last time she can die
having gotten the final bit of closure
she needs and he can be free to live his
life unburdened the secret tragedy is
that Coupe makes it home too late to
spend any significant amount of time
with his daughter or perhaps we have
just stumbled upon a plot contrivance by
the end murf is an elderly woman who has
stayed alive long enough to finally see
her father again who looks the same as
when he left decades ago the whole movie
is built on this relationship so people
are rightfully confused as to why they
only spend a few minutes together murf
now realizes this reunion is the last
thing that is driving her to live and
she can finally let go she even says to
Coupe that she doesn't have much time
left and that a father shouldn't watch
their child die even given this you
would think Coupe and murf would each
want some more than just 5 minutes it is
a stunningly brief final encounter
considering how much energy he spends
trying to return to her in the first
place understanding the emotional core
at the center of interstellar requires
understanding how time dilation Works
once the crew of the endurance reaches
Miller's Planet full of treacherous
waves it is assumed the audience
understands this concept but how exactly
does the time dilation make sense in
interstellar the explanation the movie
gives is that a difference in
gravitational force causes time to move
at different speeds on different planets
this dilation effect is accelerated when
in the case of Millers the planet is
orbiting a black hole as the force of
gravity increases time moves at an
accelerated Pace while Coupe and his
crew only spent a few hours crash landed
on Miller's Planet 23 years have passed
on Earth according to scientist Neil
degrass Tyson this detail of
interstellar is a scientific phenomenon
that exist for real this can be proven
by Einstein's equation of general
relativity that's relativity folks one
of the first unanswered questions you
might have when you watch Interstellar
is when exactly does the movie take
place it's a good question that isn't
ever EXP implicitly stated in
Christopher Nolan's movie however you
can piece a relatively precise estimate
together based on a conversation from
early on in the film in one of the first
scenes we see Coupe attending a baseball
game with his family in an off-handed
comment to his family coup's
father-in-law says my day we had real
ball players who are these bumps and in
the scene where Donald and Cooper talk
on the porch the Elder says when I was a
kid it felt like they made something new
every day some Gadget or idea this
sounds a lot like what growing up in the
past 10 to 15 years has been like we can
safely assume that between growing up
with professional baseball and
Technology Donald is a millennial using
this knowledge we can place the events
of interstellar about 50 to 60 years
after present Day 2014 when the movie
came out this means the film probably
takes place in the late 21st century
while even Donald's demise gets a
passing reference dad didn't raise me
Grandpa did and he's buried out back
murf's brother Tom is the only character
in interstellar whose face is a complete
mystery so what exactly has happened to
coup's Son by the time he returns home
from the TCT well logically the easiest
answer is to assume Tom died for one he
was older than murf who is already
extremely old by the end so his time was
naturally up additionally in the final
scenes of interstellar we see that the
only thing allowing murf to hold on to
her life is belief that her dad will
return Tom as a character was defined by
his lack of faith and belief in Coupe
his absence at the end of the movie
speaks to the power of Mercy Love and
Hope and how they were the only things
keeping her alive you can also argue
that his single purpose in the story is
served in his final scene Tom's function
in the plot is ultimately to push murf
to solve the bookshelf puzzle his
purpose is fulfilled when she finally
does and afterward there really isn't
any narrative reason for Tom to reappear
one of the more confusing worldbuilding
elements is the current state of NASA in
the film it's never explained quite why
NASA folded though it seems that the
general populace and Interstellar lost
faith in the organization years before
the events of the film basically what we
are given in the final film is that NASA
is no longer seen as necessary when
people all around the world are starving
this aspect of the movie is explained
more thoroughly in the 2008 original
script that Christopher Nolan's brother
Jonathan worked on for Steven Spielberg
in that early draft the film begins with
NASA engineers and a young John brand
investigating a wormhole 50 years later
the NASA probe they had sent out crash
lands on Earth this is eventually what
leads Coupe to NASA instead of the ghost
angle taken in the final film in the
early version of the story it is
explained that 30 years before the
film's events NASA folded as a result of
the blight that nearly destroyed all of
humanity while the rise of Skywalker
answered a number of the saga's
lingering questions it also presented a
few of its own we can't promise you'll
understand every part of episode 9 after
delving into our explanations but we
hope we can help you feel at least a
little less
confused the rise of Skywalker wastes no
time in telling us that she Palpatine
the emperor from the original trilogy
that we all presumed was dead after the
end of Return of the Jedi is actually
alive in fact Palpatine has been pulling
the strings of the first order this
whole time the first order Rose from the
Dark Side while we never get a detailed
explanation for Palpatine's survival we
should have known better than to assume
a fall would kill a strong force user
like Palpatine especially since both
Darth Maul and Luke Skywalker survived
pretty serious Falls in past Star Wars
cannon after return of the Jedi
Palpatine slunk off to the Sith planet
of exagal where Sith loyalists used
machines to artificially prolong his
life similar to how Darth Vader was
stabilized after his battle with Obi-Wan
in Revenge of the Sith once on exigal
Palpatine bited his time in the shadows
waiting until his fleet was strong
enough to reveal itself the opening
crawl of Rise of Skywalker mentions that
newly Meed supreme leader kylo Ren is
searching for Palpatine determined to
destroy any threat to his power the film
then reveals kylo Ren on the surface of
a glowing red planet slaughtering a
forest full of faceless opponents before
ultimately locating a Sith wayfinder
that once belonged to his grandfather
Darth Vader that wayfinder reveals the
way to exigal where kylo Ren confronts
Palpatine and learns the truth of reay's
parentage the battle for the wayfinder
takes place on Mustafar the volcano
planet where Anakin Skywalker once
dueled his mentor Obi-Wan Kenobi this
time kylo Ren is fighting members of the
alysm of wiset a cult of Vader
worshippers guarding HTH Fortress who
also planted the unlik ly Forest of iron
trees where the battle takes place
unfortunately for the alisch kylo ran
had no interest in explaining to them
why he needed to access the ruins of
Fortress Vader and found it easier to
cut a smoldering path through his
grandfather's acolytes than to Simply
ask permission to pass Palpatine
assembles a massive final order Fleet
before the rise of Skywalker but it's
not entirely clear how he does it we
know that Palpatine was able to channel
the power of all the Sith who had come
before him that he was cloning Snokes
who were also all presum presumably
strong in the dark side of the force and
that he had a network of loyalists he
was able to tap into throughout the
Galaxy even after his presumed death we
also know based on the thousands of
shrouded figures in the throne room that
either exigal had a large native
population that was loyal to Palpatine
or that he was able to physically
manifest the countless former Sith who
resided within him either way it seems
as though Palpatine had a large and
Powerful Workforce at his decaying
fingertips and 30 years of secrecy in
which to build his army as for where he
acquired the resources to construct the
ships the rise of Skywalker visual
dictionary confirms that Palpatine was
siphoning supplies from the first order
through loyalist he had embedded within
its ranks following the death of Luke
Skywalker at the end of The Last Jedi
his twin sister Leia Orana took it upon
herself to train the four sensitive Ray
in the ways of the Jedi this might come
as a bit of a surprise considering we
never saw Leia receive any Jedi training
herself despite indications of her Force
sensitivity throughout the Star Wars
film
in the rise of Skywalker we learned that
when Leia was younger she actually did
train as a Jedi with Luke and
essentially completed her training even
constructing her own lightsaber however
on the final day of her training Leia
had a vision that her Jedi path would
lead to the death of her son which
caused her to turn away from becoming a
Jedi so while Leia technically isn't a
Jedi herself she has all the knowledge
training and capabilities necessary to
continue raise instruction where her
brother had left off when the resistance
learns that Palpatine is alive they
worry that they won't be able to stop
him since he's on exle and no one knows
how to get there however Ray remembers
that Luke Skywalker had attempted to
find exagol many years earlier while
Luke hadn't actually found the Sith
Planet he had tracked the wayfinder that
revealed its location to a desert planet
called Pana where the trail had gone
cold however when Ray leads her team to
Pana instead of the wayfinder they find
another clue it turns out that many
years ago a Sith loyalist named Ochi was
tasked with bringing the young Ray to
Palpatine on exigal and and he carried a
dagger inscribed with the coordinates of
the wayfinder but before Ochi could find
Ray he accidentally rode his feeder into
the sinking fields of Pana and died
buried beneath the planet's surface
along with the Sith
dagger after finding ochi's Sith dagger
C3PO reveals that while he can read the
coordinates inscribed on it he is
incapable of translating them for the
rest of the team as 3PO explains his
programming forbids him from translating
the Sith language under any
circumstances due to a rule passed by
the Imp IAL Senate which may date all
the way back to the prequels as we
learned in episodes 1 through 3
Palpatine spent years manipulating the
Senate from within in order to serve his
dark purposes and eventually dissolved
the Senate entirely knowing this it
makes sense that Palpatine would have
enacted legislation making it impossible
for Droids to translate Sith enabling
him to keep his true identity and master
plan hidden from his peers when Ray and
her friends prepare to leave Pana
Chewbacca gets captured and loaded onto
a transport by first order troops while
a horrified Finn looks on concerned Finn
runs to tell Ray and they both watch as
a transport takes flight from behind a
large rock formation raay tries to use
the force to pull the transport back to
the ground but after meeting opposition
from kylo Ren she becomes frustrated and
lets out a surge of energy that causes
the transport to explode which she
thinks means that chewy has died almost
immediately we find out that chewy is
actually still alive and is being held
captive on a first order ship General
hux mentions that there was actually a
second first order transport on Pana
which was the one Finn saw chewy being
loaded on to he must not have seen the
second one due to the rock formations
dotting the landscape since Ray Finn and
their companions left Pana immediately
after the transport exploded they missed
when the second one containing chewy
took off early on the rise of Skywalker
sets up the Intriguing mystery of a spy
within the first order who was passing
crucial bits of information to the
resistance this spy is later revealed to
be none other than the SN nibbling
General hux much to the shock of Finn
and Poe who are completely blindsided by
the first order officer's turn after all
hux spent the entirety of the force
awakens and The Last Jedi fervently
opposing the resistance and fighting to
advance the first ord's agenda so what
changed based on hux's explanation to
Finn he still isn't actually a friend to
the resistance and has no investment in
their ultimate Victory but as much as he
hates the resistance he hates kylo Ren
more and seems to have been motivated to
switch sides following Ren's Ascension
to supreme leader when Ren took snoke's
place hux was disgusted to find his
power significantly diminished and
seemed to hope that by aiding the
resistance he could topple kylo Ren and
subsequently seize more power for
himself between the completion of The
Last Jedi and the beginning of
production on the rise of Skywalker
Carrie Fischer who has played Leo Orana
since A New Hope in 1977 passed away
however since Leo was still very much
alive in the Star Wars Universe director
JJ Abrams announced that he would be re
working the rise of Skywalker storyline
to incorporate previously unused footage
of Fisher from the force awakens to
finish Leia's Journey this resulted in
Leia being present in the First Act of
Rise of Skywalker as Ray's teacher and
the leader of the resistance then dying
around the midpoint of the film after
reaching out to her son one final time
with the force while Leia's ending was
largely dictated by the available
archival footage of fiser her death
still provided a Bittersweet and fitting
sendoff to her character although it
appears that Leia only transmits the
name Ben through the force her son's
reaction indicates that he received more
than that perhaps it isn't only his name
that Leah Force projects to him but her
feelings of motherly love and acceptance
letting him know that even after all
he's done she still considers him her
son Leah's last ditch effort to pull her
son back from the Dark Side pays off but
the effort of reaching him takes every
bit of remaining strength she has she
dies becoming one with the force just
like her brother before her at first
glance it might seem as though kylo
Ren's transformation back into Ben solo
is confusingly abrupt but upon closer
examination Ben's decision to abandon
his Dark Side Persona is something he's
been struggling with for a long time
both in previous films and in the first
half of the rise of Skywalker before his
duel with Ray kylo tells her that he can
never go back to his mother the dark
side is the only option available to him
but when Leia contacts him during their
duel he realizes the truth he could
always go back and the only one holding
him back was himself afterward he
imagines his deceased father Han Solo
who tells him kylo Ren is dead and
counters every argument he can think of
to remain on his dark path finally when
it seems as though Ben wants to
apologize for all the evil he's done Han
replies with his iconic I know
communicating his enduring love and
forgiveness afterward Ben tosses his
Sith lightsaber into the ocean having
finally found the strength to turn back
to the light side thanks to the combined
efforts of his loving parents long
before the beginning of the force
awakens Palpatine was responsible for
the creation of snoke along with an
indeterminate number of identical snoke
clones Palpatine maneuvered snoke into a
position of power as supreme leader of
the first order and all of snoke's
orders in the first two films actually
came from Palpatine while Palpatine was
secretly shaping the first order he was
also searching for his granddaughter Ry
whom he considered his Heir he sent out
bounty hunters to find her but their
efforts failed he didn't know where she
was until she started her Force training
under Luke Skywalker he then tasked kylo
Ren with finding and killing her but he
never intended for him to succeed
instead he hoped his efforts would
Propel Ray to lean further into the dark
side preparing her to take over for
Palpatine as empress once Ray faced him
on exigal Palpatine tempted her to
strike him down and take his place just
as he once taunted Luke Skywalker
Palpatine claimed that killing him would
transfer his Spirit to Ray along with
all the past Sith and they would all
rule over the Galaxy as one after
Palpatine believes he's won Ry again
attempts the force exercise that's been
eluding her throughout the whole film
trying to channel the Jedi who have come
before her this time it works and Ry is
strengthened by a number of Jedi voices
feeding her encouragement that enables
her to face Palpatine again if some of
those voices sounded familiar there is a
reason for that the rise of Skywalker
brings back every significant Jedi from
past Star Wars movies including Hayden
Christensen as Anakin Skywalker euwan
McGregor and Alec Guinness as Obi-Wan
Kenobi Liam niss as Qui-Gon Jinn Frank
Oz as Yoda Samuel L Jackson as Ma
and of course Mark Hamill as Luke
Skywalker Additionally the scene
includes some voice actors from Star
Wars animated series who portrayed now
deceased Jedi namely Ashley exin as
Ahsoka Tano Freddy Prince Jr as Kanan
jerus Olivia dbo as luminara unduli
Jennifer hail as AA Sakura and Angelique
parin as ADI Galia the combined strength
of Ray and the spirits of the past Jedi
is enough for Ray to reflect Palpatine's
dark energy back on himself killing him
since Palpatine technically caught
causes his own death his Spirit doesn't
pass to Ray as he' planned and the Sith
line is ended no no no you are die
several times throughout the rise of
Skywalker characters mention that Ray
and kylo ran make up a diad in the force
a new term we've never heard of in
previous Star Wars films diads are
extremely rare and the two of them
together can wield the force and
Powerful ways that haven't been seen in
Generations kylo Ren speculates that
their unique nature is due to them being
the grandchildren of two of the greatest
Force users in history Anakin Skywalker
and Emperor Palpatine when Palpatine
realizes that Ray and Ben are stronger
together than either of them are
separately he heals his decrepit Body by
draining their combined Force energy
then tries to weaken them by splitting
them up Ray is still able to defeat
Palpatine by channeling the strength of
past Jedi but the effort completely
drains and kills her however Ben is able
to revive Ray by transferring all of his
energy to her through the force which
ultimately kills him before before he
dies though he and Ry are able to share
a few grateful moments of life together
likely made possible by the strength of
their shared
Bond Zack Snider's Justice League is an
ambitious 4H hour epic packed with tons
of previously unseen footage as well as
contradictions and unexplained moments
here are those confusing moments
explained of all the minor continuity
discrepancies between the DC EU movies
one of the most noticeable is the case
of Aquaman's eye color if you've missed
out on the Weeden cut of Justice League
back in 2017 then you may be used to the
brown yellows closer to Jason momoa's
natural eye color and James Juan's
Aquaman in the 2017 Justice League
Aquaman can be seen with striking baby
blues this coloring was brought back
again in the SNY cut leaving some
viewers reasonably confused as it turns
out this is a choice both directors are
very aware of and site as an artistic
difference but but according to mimoa it
was a decision motivated by something
the actor himself said in an interview
with the Huffington Post promoting
Aquaman back in 2018 mimoa revealed
about the change it was my idea I
brought to Zach I thought it would be
rad to have a different eye color
something that's completely atlantian
that was like his Mark I felt like it
was just something that would be a
little otherworldly so Zach really liked
it as for why director James Juan went
in a different direction Momoa said I
feel like Juan wanted to have a warmer
thing in this movie I feel like my
justification for the change is that he
kind of went home he's more rooted and
he's calm when he's around his family
another inconsistency between Aquaman
Batman versus Superman dawn of Justice
and Zack Snider's Justice League has no
real bearing on their overall plots but
is a detail that can be irksome to
anyone following the DCU releases thus
far it's time to talk about the Trident
in Zack Snider's Justice League Queen at
Atlanta's Trident is presented to
Aquaman by volco volco encourages
Aquaman to take the Trident and claim
his Birthright to the throne of Atlantis
he declines setting up the 2018 Aquaman
Arc in the theatrical version of the
film this was replaced by a scene
between mea and Aquaman after Steen wolf
steals the Mother Box hidden in Atlantis
it's implied that Mira gives Aquaman the
Trident that he uses to fight in the
rest of the film in both cuts of the
film he uses the Trident during battle
with parademon but the moment where
Aquaman seems to ask for the Trident
doesn't exist in the SN cut then I'm
going to need something from
you however that still doesn't explain
the footage first shown in Snider's
previous movie Batman vers Superman
which shows Aquaman with a trident that
looks pretty much exactly like the
weapon he wields in Justice League does
Aquaman just have an extra Trident that
looks just like his mother's this is
another perplexing moment that as a
result of creative changes made
following the lackluster theatrical
releasee of Justice League the way
Snider envisioned underwater
Communications between atlantans works
just fine for his movie but James Juan
made some changes to fit his vision for
Aquaman in both versions of Justice
League all underwater conversations
between atlanteans happen in air bubbles
they create in James Juan's Aquaman the
atlantans no longer require these
bubbles to speak to each other
underwater why did this happen whenever
you notice something like that a wizard
did it well not really Juan said in an
Entertainment Weekly interview people
are overthinking it they're just going
to talk honestly it's hard to imagine
him having any other stance SNY stylish
portrayal of Atlantean communication
would have quickly become annoying in a
movie that takes place primarily in
Atlantis to many who grew up with the
Justice League comics and cartoons Green
Lantern is a core member of The League
sadly the Colossal bomb that was 2011's
Green Lantern movie with Ryan re
ensured that DC won't be touching Hal
Jordan for a good while but it seems
like Snyder has put the wheels in motion
to one day bring Green Lantern back into
the fold the climax of the second part
of Zack Snider's Justice League is a
flashback of Epic Proportions it depicts
the first Age of Heroes and the final
battle between dark side and the humans
atlanteans and Amazon the one Lantern
visible Yen gur was in the original cut
but in the SN cut he explicitly dies by
dark side's hand the scene also
highlights how the ring escaped and
continued the hero's line which
presumably would have been followed up
on in a future Justice League sequel Yen
gur wasn't the only lantern that made an
appearance in the SN cut kilowog set up
to be one of the main characters in HB
Max's Green Lantern core series appears
dead in Cyborg's vision of the desolate
future timeline AKA The Nightmare one of
the most surprising and unusual changes
made to the SN cut comes from a
character who who isn't in the movie for
a terribly long amount of screen time
still it's enough to notice how Snyder
has made merera change her accent or at
least it seems that way the truth is
probably much simpler in Aquaman and
2017's Justice League herd voiced the
Atlantean Queen with an accent that
sounded more or less like her regular
speaking voice my parents fought in the
wars she took me in what a saint you
dare speak of Queen Atlanta that way Z
Snider's Justice League has heard
putting on a British accent my parents
died in the
wars she took me in what a
saint you dare speak of queen atlana
that way it's likely that the original
scenes with mirror for the movie were
already completely finished and were
simply added back for the SNY cut this
means that the mirror scenes in 2017's
Justice League are almost certainly
re-shoot this choice is minor and in
keeping with Snider's objective to
completely preserve his original vision
for the film if you are at all confused
about the scene with Lois Lane and a
green space alien impersonating Martha
Kent don't worry so are we later
revealing himself to Bruce Wayne and to
the DC Universe At Large Martian
Manhunter AKA Jon Jones makes his live
action debut in Zack Snyder's Justice
League in a mysterious scene at the end
of a long conversation between Lois and
Martha about Clark Martha exits and
unbeknownst to Lois shape shifts for
into Martian Manhunter and then into
Secretary of Defense Calvin swanwick in
the scene Martha advises Lois that she
still needs to be part of society which
motivates her to get out placing her in
the right place at the right time when
Superman is brought back to life this
moment is pivotal and the knowledge that
Martian Manhunter was orchestrating
events in the movie the whole time is
mindblowing Martian Manhunter was one of
the original Justice League members and
his appearance of the SN verse brings
the League's new Total up to that oh so
important number seven now that we know
what Snyder planned for two Justice
League sequels we know he was going to
expand the group and bring in Green
Lantern and other DC Legends but now the
future of Martian Manhunter in the DCU
remains
uncertain a very important part of the
SN verse is the nightmare it's never
really explained in either Batman versus
Superman dawn of Justice or Zack Snider
Justice League nor is it referred to by
name still understanding it is vital to
understanding the greater meaning behind
many of the new additions to the SN cut
the nightmare is introduced in Batman vs
Superman when Bruce dreams of being in a
Sandy washed out desert after being
ambushed by a group of men Batman sees
parad demons coming in the distance and
is overtaken this Vision concludes with
the reveal of an evil Superman and Bruce
being awoken to a flash from the future
future telling him Lois is the key it's
a reference to what happens in Justice
League but also is a clue to her
importance in the now shuttered sequel
SNY was planning the nightmare itself
makes a return in the SNY cut where it
becomes clear that dark side is the
cause of the apocalyptic future it's
never explicitly stated but Snyder has
explained that this is a vision of the
future that must be stopped in the SN
cut we see Superman holding the burned
body of Lois in the Batcave which is the
turn point that Bruce must never let
happen there's a lot to love about Zack
Snider's Justice League but admittedly
it doesn't explain some of its biggest
Concepts such as what exactly is the
anti-life equation and why does dark
side want it so badly originally created
for DC's fourth world Arc in 1970 the
anti-life equation is a secret way of
controlling all sensient beings Dark
Side believes part of the equation
exists in the subconscious of humanity
which is why steephen wolf interrogates
people using those creepy spider bugs
thematically a common interpretation is
that the equation is a mathematical
proof of the futility of living and a
way to dominate Humanity through
spreading hopelessness what it actually
is and whether or not it has a physical
form in the SN verse is one of the
biggest mysteries for the future of the
DCU it's not explained at all in the
movie but Superman's pitch black suit
has great historical significance that
references one of Snyder's key
Inspirations for his Justice League the
black suit in Zack Snyder's Justice
League is a reference to 1993's the
reign of Superman comic Arc the followup
to previous years The Death of Superman
which saw Superman die while fighting
doomsday when he comes back to life in
Rain he's wearing the black suit in an
iconic moment of DC Comics history since
then it has always been associated with
the death and Return of Superman in the
lore the suit was designed to help the
weakened Superman absorb more solar
energy so he can be stronger after
coming back to life while this may be
obvious to older DC Comics fans it's not
left unexplained for no reason there was
actually a deleted scene that was shot
during Snider's original production that
showed a newly resurrected Superman
choosing to Dawn either a suit of
Kryptonian armor or the iconic black
suit Joe manganelo joined the DC
universe's Deathstroke in a mid-credit
scene in the theatrical cut of Justice
League back in 2017 the yacht scene that
served as his introduction is in the SN
cut but in an altered form however the
restored version of the scene is more
confusing than anything else in the
theatrical Justice League Deathstroke's
introduction was a teaser for a legion
of do movie where Luther gathers a band
of villains to face off against the
Justice League shouldn't we have a
league of Our
Own in the version of the scene that
made it into the SN cut Luther tells
Deathstroke Batman's true identity which
is a significant difference at the time
Snyder's intention was to make a
standalone Ben Affleck Batman film
following Justice League with magel's
Deathstroke serving as the main villain
Affleck dropped out and the Batman
eventually turned into the Robert
patternson lead Matt Reeves directed
project currently in production now both
versions of Justice League have scenes
teasing movies that will never see the
light of day The Nightmare scene in the
epilog is the most dire of all parody
demons roam the land while Batman and
the rest of the league are at the end of
their rope Aquaman is dead replaced by
mea Deathstroke is working with the
league and Flash is wearing his future
costume from the Batman versus Superman
flashback Jared Leto's Joker makes his
return to mock The Dark Knight one last
time he and Batman make important
references to the deaths of Robin Harley
Quinn and Lois Lane before Joker offers
Bruce a truce the sequence ends with the
league preparing for for what might just
be one last battle at the end of the
world with Superman the scene is loaded
with implications about what might have
happened in the future of the SN verse
it confirms the death of Robin at the
hands of the Joker and that Bruce
letting Lois die in a tragic blast is
the turning point of the conflict
according to Snyder this tragedy allows
Superman to succumb to the anti-life
equation and therefore fall completely
under dark side's control time travel
and multiverses were going to play a
major role in Justice League two and
three but now this single scene is the
most we'll see of Zack Snyder's dark
Justice League
Trilogy Close Encounters of the huh kind
horses in the night skies Cowboys and
aliens and predators all feature in
Jordan peele's newest film nope and you
don't need access to any X Files to
understand it all keep watching for the
confusing moments in nope explained
early in the film nope introduces OJ
Haywood and his father o senior the two
run a horse ranch with a side business
of wrangling the animals for Hollywood
films and their intro scene starts off
pretty quiet and peaceful that is until
an array of objects start raining from
the sky like daggers one of which
fatally wounds Otis the scene is pretty
clearly explained via the later events
in the film but it can be a bit
confusing at first while OJ is told by
the authorities that the items likely
fell out of an airplane he doesn't buy
that explanation eventually he discovers
that a giant alien monster is to blame a
creature that vomits out any non-organic
material after feeding so presumably the
alien was passing overhead after a meal
cloaked in its cloud cover and
unfortunately decided to spit up some
keys and coins directly over Haywood
Ranch following the brutal opening combo
of Gordy's home and otis' death nope
launches into a full opening credit
sequence something that seen less and
less in modern movies but common to the
classic genre flicks that peel pulls
from the only thing is it's it's hard to
tell exactly what's going on during the
opening credits the names appear in the
middle of an oscillating landscape of
waves almost like the viewer is sitting
inside an otherworldly blanket fort
eventually the camera Zooms in to reveal
a man riding a horse a clip later
explained to be the first movie ever
made it's impossible to discern what's
happening your first time watching the
nope opening credits but after going
through the full film it becomes much
clearer the camera shot that displays
the credits is the same shot used used
to show the inside of the alien's mouth
later on the flags from the decoy are
repeatedly shown dangling out the
billowing Ma and the shot is used again
in the star lasso experience scene when
the creature devours a whole shows worth
of people this could just be a fun
Easter egg for folks on their second
viewing but it can also be read as
thematically significant Ricky refers to
the UFO as the viewers and that's also
what you are when you're watching the
movie rattling off the cast and crew
from the perspective of of the monster
makes that connection even more explicit
and the texture of the alien also
foreshadows its final form after getting
kicked off the set of commercial OJ and
emerald head to the Wild West theme park
Jupiter's claim owned by the enigmatic
Ricky Park specifically OJ goes there to
sell another horse lucky to Ricky having
already sold him almost a dozen while in
the meeting OJ brings up the notion of
buying a few of the horses back which
causes Ricky to pause and eventually
change the subject this scene makes a
lot more sense with the context of the
rest of the movie It's implied that
Ricky has been experimenting with the
alien for some time by feeding at horses
a grim act that eventually becomes the
centerpiece of his star lasso experience
Ricky probably bulks at the idea of
selling OJ the horses back because well
they're not around anymore instead of
discussing the issue Ricky switches
gears and tells Emerald all about his
experience shooting the sitcom Gordy's
home the site of the violent incident
pictured in the first scene this moment
also foreshadows the star lasso
experience as it shows Ricky's ability
to ignore trauma and potential danger in
the interest of turning a profit after
setting up security cameras all around
the ranch and preparing for the UFO's
return OJ has what seems at first to be
a real alien encounter in the horse's
Stables while investigating some strange
activity he comes upon three big headed
beings covered in coarse black hair it's
one of the film's spookier scenes but it
ends up being a complete fake out as the
aliens are nothing more than three kids
in costumes specifically they're the
children of Ricky Park showing up later
on in the same costumes to perform at
the star lasso experience after their
cover is blown they tell OJ not to mess
with Jupiter's claim and quickly leave
OJ seems to think it's because Emerald
stole one of the Park's horse statues
but there might be more at play than
simple payback it suggested at various
points that Ricky is interested in
purchasing the whole Haywood Ranch given
that his newest business business
venture involves chasing down a UFO that
lives in the area that makes a lot of
sense considering that it's possible the
kid's prank would have been just the
start of a campaign to compel OJ to sell
businessmen using skevy tactics to force
people to sell property is a classic
Western Trope and it feels right at home
in
nope arguably the most graphic and
striking scene in all of nope happens
after the alien eats the people at the
star lasso experience the creature
descends directly over the Haywood W
house and begins releasing all manner of
objects coins keys and a giant statue of
a horse all get jettisoned out of the
creatures M but it also spew a veritable
hail storm of blood and viscera from its
recently consumed meal in other words
the alien starts riging literal blood
over the Haywood house it's above
us the spark for this horrifying moment
is the aliens Feast at Jupiter's claim
it sucks up way more people and other
assorted items than ever before so it
makes sense that its release ends up
being so massive why it chooses to dump
all over the Haywood house specifically
however is a bit less clear the best
explanation is probably OJ's own it's a
territorial animal and it's marking its
territory despite being one of the two
lead protagonists of nope OJ Haywood
doesn't get a ton of overt character
development he's a quiet and Solitary
Man Who seems to prefer the company of
horses to that of humans but he also
doesn't seem to love the Hollywood work
that his father pushed him into even UFO
attacks and Raining Blood barely get a
rise out of OJ who willingly returns to
the ranch Time After Time despite the
inherent
danger no why does OJ do this knowing
that he could get abducted and devoured
you could read it as OJ wanting the
money Emerald claims that a great shot
of the alien will make them rich and
famous which would definitely be a
motivating factor for most people but is
it the kind of thing that OJ would care
about as OJ tells Emerald before
returning to the ranch he's got mouths
to feed he clearly feels a familial
obligation to take care of the horses
and keep the ranch going he stays in the
Hollywood business in large part because
it's what Otis would have wanted and he
may see exposing the alien as a way of
paying tribute to his father as well if
there is money to be made from the alien
it would mean that OJ wouldn't need to
sell any more horses which seems good
enough for him the clim a of nope is a
complicated sequence and there are a lot
of things that are easy to miss your
first time watching it essentially the
whole group lays out an elaborate plan
to capture the alien fully on camera
each character has their own motivations
with Angel wanting to expose
extraterrestrials to the public Emerald
seeking out the fame and fortune a great
shot could bring and Holst seeking out
some kind of artistic achievement by
making an impossible shot the shot the
money shot undeniable Singler the the op
Shad one of the more confusing parts of
the plan involves the dozens of sky
dancers that the crew sets up all around
the wrench at first they look like
they're meant as distractions but
they're actually a sort of radar system
because anything electrical conks out
when near the alien you can tell where
the creature is by which Sky Dancers get
turned off the electrical issues are
also why Holst brings an old-fashioned
hand crank camera which doesn't rely on
any modern power source to operate
finally OJ uses a parach late in a
string of flags the same kind that
temporarily incapacitates the alien
earlier in the movie as a means to
briefly scare it off once the UFO gets
on him and he rides into position for
the shot he releases the string into the
air to dissuade the alien from eating
him and lucky the plan works and both OJ
and lucky make it out in one piece for
his climactic ride on Lucky OJ chooses
to wear the orange crew hoodie he got
from working on the set of the Scorpion
King with his father he mentions the
film much earlier during a conversation
with Emerald who shares that jean jacket
the horse that was supposed to be her
first was the one brought along for the
shoot the Scorpion King generally seems
to symbolize the complicated
relationship that the Haywood siblings
had with their father it was the first
job that OJ got brought along for it
marked a Schism between Otis and emerald
and because jean jacket didn't even end
up being used in the film it also
represents unfinished business he even
goes so far as to dub the alien jean
jacket all of these little details
surely play into OJ's decision to wear
the hoodie he brings in all these Loose
Ends from his relationship with his
father and it seems like he gets some
closure by confronting the alien of
course the hoodie is functionally
relevant as its bright orange color is
easy for both the alien and the rest of
the crudy and it's big enough for OJ to
wrap himself in what looks to be a
bulletproof vest for Extra Protection
Emerald even sews some ey likee
reflectors into the back of the hood to
help get the creatures attension when
the time comes just as everything is set
for the big alien shoot the crew gets
disrupted by the surprise arrival of a
poparazzi reporter riding in on an
electric motorcycle with a striking
Chrome helmet that completely obscures
his face the reporter quickly begins
badgering Emerald with questions about
the strange incidents in the area
because he looks like a robot from the
future it's natural to assume at first
that the motorcycle man has some
ulterior motive for being there but in
the end he just dies in a relatively in
ceremonious fashion the main reasons for
him showing up seem to be getting
Emerald a motorcycle something she
references early on and offering another
bit of meta commentary like Hol the
reporter is there to get the shot even
as he's lying on the ground about to die
he implores OJ to take a picture of him
nope dabbles heavily in the idea of
seeing and being seen on camera or
otherwise for a guy so obsessed with
being seen and getting the perfect shot
it's more than a little ironic that he
was eaten by a creature that definitely
saw him shockingly the whole plan to
capture footage of the UFO goes
perfectly at least until Hol decides to
take a camera with him up a hill where
he's quickly eaten by the monster Holst
is a curious character throughout the
film to say the least whenever he's
shown editing film it's mostly nature
shots of predators fighting he agrees to
help out when Emerald promises an
opportunity to get the impossible shot
which suggests that he's still chasing
some kind of artistic Peak and yet once
he has the shot Hol seems to lose all
sense of himself we don't deserve the
impossible he says before climbing up
the hill with his camera this seems like
a declaration of intent Holst willingly
travels to higher and more dangerous
ground with the camera in toe in an
attempt to make the shot even more
perfect and what's more perfect than
what he already has more of the alien at
Golden hour he films the alien's
approach and attack even as his camera
is destroyed along with him he gets the
shot at the ultimate
price how does the time reset actually
work why are they called mimics here are
the answers to your biggest questions
about Edge of Tomorrow in the film's
opening Montage we learn that a meteor
has crashed to Earth bringing with it an
invasive extraterrestrial species that
humans call mimics they've been
spreading across Europe for years easily
overcoming all conventional military
defenses to combat this alien menace the
world's governments join together to
form the United Defense Force or UDF and
begin manufacturing suits of powered
armor for their infantry when the UDF
has their first victory at the Battle of
Verdun the belief is that the new Mech
suits have proven their worth after all
Sergeant Rita vaski was able to use one
to perform incredible and daring Feats
despite limited experience proving that
anyone with minimal training can operate
one efficiently with a new jacket
technology and limited amount of
training we've been able to create super
soldiers in actuality Rita's apparently
instant Mastery of the armor and the
battlefield were the result of her
ability to repeat any day in which she
dies giving her unlimited replays of any
deadly scenario since the UDF is unaware
of this and refus to believe it in any
of Rita's previous lives they move
forward confidently with an aggressive
Invasion of France operation downfall
however Rita and her Ally Dr Carter
suspect there's still another layer to
the Battle of redun they believe that
the mimics eventually allowed the UDF to
win at for done in order to lend them a
false sense of confidence prompting an
allout assault that would allow the
mimics to annihilate the UDF in a single
stroke it's also possible that the
mimics accepted the result of the battle
of Verdun that ended with Rita losing
her ability to reset deciding that this
was Victory enough throughout the story
of Edge of Tomorrow the shape-shifting
alien menace that's conquering Earth is
always referred to as the mimics it's a
cool sounding name that helps to uniify
the film's villain avoiding the constant
reuse of of the words alien or enemy
however although the mimics do look and
move in a strange everchanging way it's
never exactly clear who or what it is
they're mimicking to find an answer to
this question you'd have to go back to
the source material the light novel all
you need is Kill by Hiroshi sakur ruaka
there it's explained that the aliens
based their Earthly shape on the first
life form they encountered after crash
landing on our planet a starfish this
idea isn't really represented in the
film with the mimics receiving a totally
original design that doesn't map easily
onto anything in our Animal Kingdom
their forms are constantly changing
their metallic tentacles forming into
legs or sharp spikes or unraveling so
they can rest flat in the dirt beneath
their prey since the mimics bodies are
incredibly fast and perpetually
reshaping themselves the audience rarely
gets a good long look at them ironically
this makes them one of the more
interesting and memorable alien designs
in recent memory since we get an idea as
to what they look like but would
struggle to describe them to another
person starfish doesn't really cut it
and neither does any other comparison
mimic will have to do when cage rescues
Sergeant Rita vaski on the battlefield
demonstrating a clear for knowledge of
the dangers around them Rita realizes
that he must be on a Time Loop find me
when you wake up in his next life cage
finds Rita and learns that months
earlier she also absorbed the blood of
an alpha mimic gaining the ability to
start the day over upon her death
however she lost that ability on her
last Loop during which she managed to
win the Battle of Verdun but also
suffered serious non-lethal blood loss
when she received a transfusion of new
normal blood she lost the ability to
reset the day upon hearing this we can't
help but ask one logical question how
can Rita possibly know that she no
longer resets time when she dies unless
she died and didn't come back this
unfortunately is something the viewer
simply has to accept in order for the
movie to work to patch up this potential
plot hole we're forced to accept that
and a later cage can simply feel that
their ability to reset time is gone we
see it happen to cage after he suffers
his own similar injury and blood
transfusion in the final Loop of the
film is it beyond belief that mimic
Alphas would have such a sixth sense
that allows them to know whether or not
they're detached from the time stream
not entirely one can imagine that such
an instinct might have evolved within
mimics in order to alert an alpha that
it's lost its metaphysical Save State
still it's certainly convenient for Our
Heroes and for the a
Dr Carter does a pretty solid job of
explaining the mechanics of edge of
tomorrow's time travel during his
initial meeting with cage While most
mimics are of the animalistic Soldier
variety there are two special kinds of
mimic that together give them their
unique advantage over Humanity their
movements are governed by a massive
Omega mimic a strange and stationary
creature with the power to skip
backwards in time by about one day
however the Omega can only do this when
its counterpart the alpha mimic is
killed this is basically a defensive
reflex while the Omega remains hidden
the alpha goes into battle if the alpha
is killed that means a battle has not
gone as well as possible and should be
attempted again with the benefit of this
experience in short the mimics are saves
coming the war for earth when cage is
infused with the Alpha's Blood on the
battlefield he acquires the Alpha's
ability to trigger the omega's time
reset the Omega is still the one
altering time but its reflex is kicked
every time cage dies instead of when the
alpha dies cage gets the added benefit
of countless replays and accumulated
experience giving him an advantage in
battle like Rita before him cage only
loses this power once enough of his
blood has been replaced because the
mimics activities and motivations are
kept a mystery from the audience we
never definitively learn what effect
Cage's blood infusion has on the Mimi's
own abilities whether or not the Alpha's
death would still trigger a time reset
while cage has the power is never
totally clear since we don't see an
alpha killed between the first and final
versions of operation downfall however
since the mimics Behavior remains
predictable in the time Loop we can
safely assume that they're not retaining
Knowledge from each reset the only
changing factor is Cage's psychic
Visions from the Omega which grow
stronger after each Loop this is how the
mimics eventually figure out that cage
has become the new reset trigger setting
a trap for him with a fake vision of the
omega's location in this Loop the mimic
Alpha Corners cage and deliberately
keeps him from killing himself
apparently trying to capture him alive
so as not to lose this progress cage
manages to reset anyway and the mimics
never seem to pay special attention to
him again this implies that they only
know of his unique nature on Loops in
which he gives it away before their
final charge towards the Omega during
their final Loop Rita and cage share a
brief moment during which Rita commends
cage on his bravery during their work
together just before charging into
battle Rita kisses cage on the lips
saying that she wishes she'd gone to to
know him better it's not totally
unreasonable to think that Rita might
just want a Last Kiss Before Dying
especially when the available willing
partner is a fellow soldier who looks
like Tom Cruz however the moment Rings a
little false when you consider that
while cage has known Rita for years
through the repetition of the time Loop
Rita has only known cage for about a day
and a half true there have been Loops
during which cage and Rita have grown
close over the course of a long road
trip but even then Rita remains an
emotionally guarded person who hesitates
to let herself feel for cage because
each Loop implies the repetition of some
but not all of the routines that cage
and Rita follow on their usual paths we
actually don't see very much of cage and
this version of Rita so this is one of
the reasons why the kiss raises some
eyebrows in an essay for the wire film
critic Esther Zuckerman described the
last second romantic twist to be a
betrayal of the character for the sake
of offering cage a reward for his
personal growth over the course of the
film indeed the moment plays as if it's
more about demonstrating that cage is no
no longer the loathsome unlovable weasel
that we meet at the start of the film
then it is about Rita learning to trust
again as previously mentioned the film
is based on a novel by Hiroshi sakur
ruaka entitled all you need is kill
according to an interview with variety
Warner Brothers president of marketing
Su coll found that audiences were put
off by movies with the word kill in the
title leading to the Project's
rebranding director Doug Lyman on the
other hand later told den of geek that
the film was renamed to accommodate the
film's tone which is significantly
lighter than that of the source material
he suggested that the film be renamed
Live Die Repeat instead someone at
Warner Brothers wasn't fond of this
title and bequeathed the project the
more generic sounding title Edge of
Tomorrow against lyman's objections Live
Die Repeat was used as a tagline for the
movie instead Lyman feels that this
contributed to the film underperforming
at the box office despite critical
Acclaim someone must have listened
because when the movie was released on
home video months later lived I repeat
was suddenly the large print on the box
and digital marketplaces listed the full
title as Live Die Repeat edge of
tomorrow depending on when you purchased
a physical copy of the movie it may
feature the two titles in a different
order Doug Lyman said that the sequels
working title is Liv die repeat repeat
and that its release would canonize
lived Die Repeat as the title of the
first film what take you so long once
cage has lost the ability to reset time
he and Rita lead a suicide mission to
destroy the Omega which is hidden under
the loua museum in Paris their mission
is successful as cage is able to drop a
belt of live grenades into the omega's
mouth cage and the alpha are caught in
the blast as well and it appears that
cage lives long enough to absorb some of
their blood then he wakes up at an
earlier point in the timeline than he's
accustomed to before his disgraceful
demotion to private and learns that the
mimics have lost their capacity to fight
the war instead of a bloody trench
battle operation downfall will now be
met with minimal resistance from the
Extraterrestrial myal Menace this seems
awfully convenient for cage who has now
saved not only the world but his own
career and reputation the film didn't
give us a clear explanation as to why
this has happened but we can extrapolate
one from the logic of the film it may be
that cage absorbing the omega's blood
has a different effect than just
absorbing the alphas giving him more
control over the time stream than he had
as merely the trigger for the reset he
may have instinctively selected a moment
in time to return to that would put him
in the best possible position
co-screenwriter Christopher mcari
promised in a since deleted tweet that
the sequel will concretely answer this
question I'll see you tomorrow arguably
one of the biggest points of confusion
surrounding Edge of Tomorrow was why it
wasn't really considered a hit before
the film was even released the Press was
already prepared to write off edge of
tomorrow as a flop whether this is the
fault of the generic sounding title or
the marketing campaign's failure to
convey the high concept is still up for
debate in any case Edge of Tomorrow
opened at number three of at the box
office losing the weekend to the
tear-jerking romance The Fault in Our
Stars and the liveaction Disney Fantasy
Maleficent the film grossed about $100
million at the US box office and another
$270 million overseas but its reported
budget was 178 million it's also worth
noting that projecting Edge of Tomorrow
to be a failure fit into a popular
narrative that Tom Cruz's star was
fading in the United States his previous
three films Oblivion Jack Reacher and
Rock of Ages were all considered to have
underperformed domestically so it's
possible that the atmosphere around the
film's release was already
poisoned John Wick chapter 4 is finally
here and we've got some questions who is
the harbinger what's the deal with
Winston and could this really be the end
for everyone's favorite assassin the
shocking end of John Wick chapter 3 saw
Winston shoot John Wick right off the
roof of the Continental when John sees
Winston again in chapter 4 however he
doesn't seem to have a problem with him
so so here's a question when Winston
shot John was he really shooting to kill
Winston knows the high table doesn't
pull its punches when it comes to
punishment so it tracks that he really
did try to kill Jon to meet the table's
demand of course it also tracks that
Winston knows his way around a
bulletproof suit he's also more than
aware that JN can take a hit and fall
off a building without going down for
the count very well gentlemen the
Continental will now be reconsecrated
there is also a clear bond between the
two men and Winston even seems paternal
towards at times you can't help but
think that he shut John to save his life
rather than end it high table be damned
for all of Winston's talk about rules
being what keeps a man separate from the
animals he can't help being a man of
instinct himself while he defers to top
dogs like the adjudicator Winston stops
at nothing to protect the rest of his
pack even if he isn't always successful
John Wick sets out to bring down the
high table in John Wick chapter 4 but he
doesn't start in New York instead he
heads to Morocco to chase down the new
Elder but why does John kill this elder
in the third installment of the John
Wick franchise Jon spends an eternity
walking through the desert to find the
Elder Jon's hope is that this mysterious
figure will reinstate him to the
Assassin's Guild the Elder demands
John's ring finger in exchange for
removing the price tag on his head in
chapter four John is back in the desert
ready to kill this second Elder for not
being able to give him back the wedding
ring the old Elder took the new Elder
clearly doesn't know how to read the
room and tells JN he'll only know peace
when he's dead this leads to Jon killing
him and sends a high t into punishment
hyperdrive while this Kill Shot sets off
the event of the movie it also speaks to
the series tragic Arc of Revenge the
Elder has been replaced by a new Elder
the Marque de Grant will be replaced by
a new Marquee no matter how many Hydra
heads or Henman John Wick takes down new
ones will spring back up in their place
ready for a new fight with the same old
John Wick the John Wick films are
stuffed with symbolism pulled from Greek
and Roman methology it's a little weird
then that Winston recalls the Mythic
last words of a legendary Australian
Outlaw in John Wick's Last Ride Winston
tells Chiron that after hearing he was
to be executed the infamous Australian
Bandit Ned Kelly said such is life
clearly these words mean something to
Winston to him Ned's acceptance of his
fate was Noble yet unsettling Winston
isn't ready to accept the Fate handed to
him and his beloved Continental from the
high table however nor does he accept
that John Wick should go down without a
fight jerone then utters the same phrase
to winstom before accepting his own fate
even if audiences are shocked to see the
Marquee finish her own off this moment
makes win realized that the high table
will always take more than he can give
when the harbinger rolls up to the NC
Continental he is clearly ready to get
down to business but why is he missing a
finger and why does that missing finger
nub suspiciously twim with John Wix did
the harbinger try and fail to get out of
the high table game just like John Wick
is there some other reason he needed to
cut off a finger to prove his loyalty to
the table The Harbinger doesn't seem to
take much pleasure in enforcing the
rules unlike the smugly evil Marquee
however he doesn't back down from his
duties or try to get creative with the
rules unlike Winston himself so what's
the story this man's backstory is one of
the biggest unanswered questions in John
Wick chapter 4 The Harbinger secret is
all in his name Harbinger is another
word for a warning of what is to come
basically he is John Wick's Ghost of
Christmas Yet to Come made flesh here
had to show John what he could become if
he can't escape the high table The
Harbinger was likely once an assassin
just like John Wick one who judging from
his demeanor and Telltale finger lived
through a similar story yet suffered a
very different fate obsessed with
maintaining the supremacy of the high
table the villainous Marquee de Grant
agrees to John Wick's terms for an old
rules duel and then quickly begins to
cheat he UPS the bounty on John Wick's
head and sends his own assassins after
him the Marquee obviously has endless
riches at his disposal but what's his
story why does he have so much power and
so little Integrity the Marquee de Grant
represents how the high table's absolute
power leads to Absolute corruption he
worships the etiquette and ceremony of
the high table he is happy to exact the
pounds of Flesh and pints of blood from
those underneath him when they break the
rules but when it's his time to face the
music he chooses a proxy to fight for
him and still tries to cheat his way to
Victory the Marquee is both a
delightfully hatable villain and a
cautionary Tale in the wick verse his
power is orderly But ultimately corrupt
superficial and Hollow he demonstrates
the dangers of standing on ceremony
instead of principle and favoring
excessive shows of power over actual
skill and that in the end is his
downfall
they gave you my
name yeah in chapter 4 the blind
assassin Kan is pressed into service to
the high table where the Marquee de
groman Kan will do anything to keep his
daughter alive well and playing violin
in the Public Square even if that means
killing old friend John Wick so how does
he actually manage this okay so this is
less a statement of confusion that it is
an appreciation of Kane's creative and
Relentless fighting style for example
the slice of kan's Kane against glass
and steel is a compelling indicator of
the pain he's about to rain down on his
opponent meanwhile Kane's heightened
sense of hearing helps him locate John
Wick using the crunching glass in the
gallery scene at the Osaka Continental
however one of Kane's most unique
techniques involves the use of cleverly
placed doorbell sensors at first as
puzzling to see Kane slap a bunch of
electronic rectangles on various
surfaces in the Osaka continental's dark
kitchen it almost looks like he's
setting bomb charges but he isn't he's
just setting traps when the hi table
Stormtroopers invade the kitchen they
set off the doorbell sensors and give
Kane a precise audible Target what a
bass after John Wick kills the Elder he
seeks Refuge at Osaka's Continental in
the neon lit night John Wick seeks help
from yet another Sturm but loving
assassin Hotel manager shimaru Koji John
Wick chapter 4 implies that JN shimazu
and Kane are old assassin friends so why
does Kane attack John Wick while shimazu
risks everything to protect him the
answer is simple for shimazu friendship
is a matter of the heart and when you're
in his heart your family Kane draws a
line between friend and family to
protect his daughter his daughter means
more to him than his friendship with
John Wick and he refuses to defy the
high table because he knows they will
kill her if he doesn't kill John Wick
jamasu meanwhile knows the table will
come for him and his daughter Akira
merely for harboring John Wick in their
Hotel tasu fights just as hard for John
Wick as he does for his daughter but his
choice to be loyal to his loved ones
ultimately cost him his life then again
considering the movie's post-credit
scene it's possible that Kane's choices
will do the same for him there are two
things the Marquee loves more than
anything in this world sparkly suits and
sending messages the Marquee sends
plenty of the latter after John Wick
defies the high table including killing
P leader of the RAR Roma to punish the
crime family for Jon's actions P might
not ring any bells with viewers although
he is an off camera adoptive father
figure to John from back in his jordani
jovanovic days the director is a ruser
Roma character that audiences are more
likely to remember still the death of p
is left a bad taste in the rascar Roma
family's mouth and Jon's adoptive sister
ktia won't help JN by sponsoring his
door the Marquee unless he kills an
enemy of hers killer Harkin it looks
like we have ourselves a a genum killer
is a baddy who pulled the trigger on
poer if Jon kills his boss he gets
branded back into the r of family for a
seat at the table and a sanction shot at
Freedom by way of dueling the Marquee Mr
Nobody is one of the franchise's
mysterious newcomers appearing out of
nowhere as a fully-fledged adversary to
Mr Wick but is this man with a plan John
Wick's Friend or Foe at first Mr Nobody
appears to be yet another long-lost
friend of Jon emerging from the Shadows
to pledge his sword and attack dog to
the course he fires a shot that saves
Jon's life but it isn't because he
shares Shamu's brotherly love for Jon
nobody is trying to drive the price up
on Jon's head not save it from Rolling
while you can totally imagine a universe
in which Mr Nobody and John buddy up or
even one where nobody finds a fistful of
reasons to take up Jon's fight against
the high table by the end of the film
Nobody is pursuing a $40 million payday
that would pay for a whole lot of cargo
pants sure but why does he really need
that much well Shamir Anderson recently
told inverse isn't nobody that needs a
cash at all he said not to give away too
much but it was for his mother John Wick
chapter 4 seems to kill off John Wick
for good after taking hit after hit and
stfall after stfall John seems to meet
his end on the steps of sakur he slums
to his side in the sunrise enjoying one
last vision of the wife he lost later
the bowy king and Winston visit John's
grave he's buried next to his wife and
even though the two visitors are a
little light-hearted with their
farewells Jon stone is inscribed as he
requested so is this a clever setup for
an impossible beginning in John Wick
chapter 5 or is it really the end the
John Wick movies are such stunning
spectacles that it's easy to forget how
much effort time and talent they take to
make four years passed between the
release of John Wick chapter 3 and its
follow-up film and Keanu Reeves and Chad
stahelski have plenty on their plates
aside from the world of work the
collaborators have been working together
in one way or another since their Matrix
days who knows what their creative
partnership might yield if this is the
end of John Wick's Road although it
seems like the character will make an
appearance in the ballerina spin-off
movie it really does seem like
everyone's favorite dog avenging grief
stricken husband might be gone for good
such is
life Oppenheimer is one of director
Christopher Nolan's more straightforward
films but even this historical biopic
takes some dramatic license and makes
some choices that may have filmed goers
scratching their heads Nolan is no
stranger to depicting time in unique
ways and Oppenheimer is a great example
of that the film is told through two
distinct timelines one focused on
oppenheimer's Rise and another looking
at Lewis strauss's attempts to tear his
rival down to distinguish the two Nolan
depicts oppenheimer's view in color
while strauss's is in black and white
this could be to make it clearer to
audiences that these story lines aren't
happening at the same time but it feels
like Nolan is attempting to do something
more with this what he's trying to
accomplish is so unclear though that
Nolan had to explain it before the film
even released Nolan talked with the
Associated Press about the significance
of using black and white to denote
perspective saying I knew that I had two
timelines that we were running in the
film one is in color and that's
oppenheimer's subjective experience then
the other is a black and white timeline
it's a more objective view of his story
from a different character's point of
view while this explanation does clear
up what Nolan was going for that concept
of subjective versus objective doesn't
necessarily come through in the film
ultimately the choice makes things a
little murky both thematically and in
terms of Storytelling throughout
Oppenheimer the title character has
small visions that somewhat foreshadow
his eventual rise in quantum physics as
well as his creation of the atomic bomb
from Stars spread across rooms that
Oppenheimer is in to the rings of a
nuclear model moving in front of him
Nolan uses some mind-bending visuals
backed by some incredibly thrilling
sound design Oppenheimer sees things in
sort of different dimensions while these
moments add to the visually stunning
nature of the film The visions do make
things a tad confusing since what they
are is never really explained are they
simply meant to foreshadow oppenheimer's
future is it a look into oppenheimer's
mental state or are they tied to a
greater force in the universe at one
point a scientist character mentions
that some people are capable of seeing
the quantum realm where subatomic
particles are visible so maybe these
scenes are meant to hint at
oppenheimer's growing connection to the
subatomic world with which he would
eventually interact if that is the case
it's something that kind of breaks the
more realistic tone throughout the rest
of the film The visuals in these
sequences are really cool but they also
may leave some audience members
wondering what they were all about the
film sees Oppenheimer bring together the
most talented and knowledgeable
physicists he can find so it's no
surprise that they constantly use
scientific jargon you know Isotopes and
you know explosives you can't tell us
what you're doing in most of the teams
discussions scientific terms get thrown
around with regularity as they make new
discoveries and start new tests even for
viewers who don't know quantum physics
all that well the group flexing their
knowledge adds some fascinating Intrigue
to the scenes and even raises the stakes
in certain moments that said their
constant use of science jargon doesn't
help viewers who haven't taken some
highlevel science classes even remotely
understand what they are talking about
instead of explaining what some of these
terms mean or breaking down the concepts
on display the characters freely talk as
if General audiences have any idea what
they're discussing although these
conversations are likely meant to Simply
immerse viewers in the moment and the
perspectives of the characters it is
likely to make some viewers feel lost
there are moments where you almost want
to raise your hand and ask questions
because these characters are talking
about Concepts that are totally going
over everyone's head when Oppenheimer
first arrives at Berkeley he looks to
create more interest among the student
body in quantum physics but he's only
able to get one student to initially
join his class eventually oppenheimer's
class begins to grow and he's even able
to amass such a strong enough following
that scientific and political
discussions begin blossoming around
campus that makes for a compelling story
about oppenheimer's burgeoning influence
but it's hard to believe that only one
student would be inclined to attend his
class or that the class would be allowed
to continue with a roster of just one by
the time Oppenheimer is at Berkeley he's
already started to make a name for
himself in the science community so his
presence would surely get more people to
come to his class out of sheer curiosity
sure quantum physics wasn't necessarily
a popular subject at the time but with a
rising Talent like Oppenheimer in front
of the class it seems like more people
definitely would have shown up on the
first day and again why would Berkeley
let the class continue with just one
student the dramatic effect is there but
think about it too long and questions
begin to pop up Oppenheimer first meets
Jean tatlock at a party and it's
instantly clear that they have an
attraction and maybe some sort of faded
connection but there their relationship
never really forms into anything
meaningful and to be honest it's a
perplexing part of oppenheimer's story
the film doesn't necessarily do a great
job adding depth or meaning to
oppenheimer's romantic relationships and
his Dynamic with Jean is mostly just
confusing why is he so drawn to her when
she just constantly pushes him away and
throws his flowers in the garbage it's
mostly just a physical relationship and
they rarely show any signs of being
anything more than hookup Buddies the
film tries to characterize their
relationship as something more but never
provides the context or insight to make
viewers feel like there's something else
there by the time Oppenheimer and Jean
really show any real emotion towards
each other it's too late and this story
line is cut short it's barely even
brought up in the film's second half the
relationship ends up as a plot thread
that's left hanging and unclear as
Oppenheimer begins work on his secret
project there is a lot of stress in his
household one night Oppenheimer returns
home to the sounds of his child crying
his wife Kitty is worn out from doing
all the child care by herself self
instead of being a good father and
trying to resolve the situation himself
Oppenheimer opts instead to abandon his
kid for a while by taking him to chevel
Y so that he can take care of the baby
it's a pretty unheroic moment for the
film's Title Character to say the least
maybe the story beat is meant to show
oppenheimer's Growing obsession with the
project or hint that his two lives are
growing even further apart it's still a
bizarre moment and it's even weirder
that Chevalier and kitty never bring it
up again nor does anyone else it's not
surprising to Oppenheimer be a little
cold or uncaring towards his family
since that's kind of who he's shown to
be at times but his choice stretches
that idea a little too far without
delivering any meaningful
ramifications as the big test for the
bomb Oppenheimer and his team are
crafting near there's some reasonable
concern that the US government could
cause harm to civilians with it you are
the man who gave them the power to
destroy themselves later when the
government uses the bomb on the Japanese
cities of Hiroshima and Nagasaki to end
World War II two in the Pacific
Oppenheimer understandably starts to
feel guilt and maybe even has some
regrets about his creation however his
belief that the bomb was going to be
solely used on the Germans was very
faulty it kind of doesn't make sense
when he claims to think that he didn't
know what the government was going to do
with the bomb after Germany surrendered
maybe oppenheimer's denial that the bomb
would be used is just a way for him not
to feel responsible for what happened
and still feel proud of his creation but
it seems like he's smarter than that and
that he'd have some sort of a awareness
that if he and his team made the bomb
it'd be used at some point his whole we
don't make the choice on how the bomb
gets used mentality just feels like an
excuse to not feel responsible for the
deaths of thousands it's likely that the
book the film is based on American
Prometheus the Triumph and tragedy of
Jay Robert Oppenheimer digs further into
these mental gymnastics but the film's
depiction ultimately feels like an
incredibly smart man playing dumb to
avoid feeling bad oppenheimer's
relationship with Kitty is equally as
bizarre as his relationship with with
Jean since there's such little emotional
connection between them that viewers are
left wondering why they stay together
their relationship is barely shown in
the film and by the end it feels like
there are more reasons for them to break
up than to stay together after all
Oppenheimer has multiple Affairs during
their marriage isn't really around to
help the family out and even uproots his
family to the testing site they barely
look like they're in love throughout the
film so it's kind of strange how kitty
just stays and even defends Oppenheimer
later on maybe she's just forced to stay
with him for security reasons since she
could likely know what's going on with
the bomb but that seems a little lofty
also it's not like she hasn't left a
relationship before since she got
divorced so that they could be together
and she even stated that she wasn't
exactly thrilled to be a housewife when
they first got together Kitty has all
the reasons and history to leave
Oppenheimer but never does which is one
of the most confusing parts of the
entire film throughout all the black and
white scenes it's clear that Strauss is
desperately trying to tarnish
oppenheimer's reputation and make him
seem dangerous to the US government it's
eventually made clear that he's
concocted quite a Revenge plan to take
his former rival down for good but it
just seems so needlessly complicated
from him having to appear publicly to
dispute Oppenheimer to the back room
trial there are just so many moving
pieces and players involved that it's
tough to believe that Strauss pulled
this all together without anyone
noticing government secrets leak all the
time and despite there being security
clearance needed for almost everything
surely someone was going to spoil
strauss's fun with his plan being so
elaborate it's kind of no wonder that it
all fell apart in the end and backfired
on him Strauss attempts to show himself
to be a mastermind like his rival but
ends up with egg on his face it's not
surprising since the overly complicated
plan never really seems possible or easy
to follow in the first place after
oppenheimer's Adam bomb devastates
Hiroshima and Nagasaki he feels
responsible for the Carnage and reveals
to President Truman that he has blood on
his hands his martyrdom in the later
parts of the film May reflect his desire
for forgiveness however if he felt so
bad about what happened why does he
continue to consult and work on future
Atomic projects why doesn't he just quit
surely others might have followed in his
footsteps or the government would have
had to bend a little bit to keep him
around since Oppenheimer was a widely
recognized Name by this point and a
crucial part of the Project's success
instead he just decides to continue his
work even though he knows it could be
used for destructive and deadly purposes
oppenheimer's sense of guilt is
certainly a flimsy part of his character
maybe he felt that he had to stay on so
he could keep tabs on these projects so
nothing worse Could Happen history
offers insight into these questions but
within the confines of the film
oppenheimer's continuing work on the US
Atomic project is a very confusing
aspect of his
character director Adam wingard's
Titanic Blockbuster Godzilla versus Kong
absolutely delivers on the heavyweight
brawl promised in the title but it's
very light on logic perplexed by the
plot of Godzilla versus versus Kong here
are the most confusing moments explained
in Godzilla versus Kong major Concepts
get brief bits of exposition Hollow
Earth for example is a major plot point
but most of its history is only laid out
during the opening credits as the credit
state in 1926 an American Admiral LED an
expedition to the North Pole although
it's not clear if he found Hollow Earth
this Admiral is very clearly supposed to
be Richard E bird a real life figure who
in ex L linked to the idea of Hollow
Earth in 1926 bird voyaged to the North
Pole although whether he actually
succeeded is a matter of debate bird has
since become a pivotal figure in the
real life Hollow Earth conspiracy theory
yeah that's a thing and Godzilla versus
Kong has embraced that making him one of
the first Hollow Earth Pioneers at least
in the monster verse even if you accept
the idea that there are tunnels
burrowing through Earth hiding tropical
Landscapes and long-lost civilizations
Godzilla versus Kong's Hollow Earth is a
little confusing the gravity Paradox
allowing Kong to jump Mario Galaxy style
from one land mass to another and making
entry to Hollow Earth so dangerous
doesn't really makes sense also it's
awfully bright down there given that the
sun is on the other side of the Earth's
surface Godzilla versus Kong never
explicitly explains how all of this
works but it's easy to come up with some
suitable theories after all the concept
of Hollow Earth has been a Mainstay in
mythology folklore and cookie pseudo
science for centuries Jules Vern's 1864
novel Journey to the Center of the Earth
while explicitly fiction uses
electromagnetic phenomena a luminous
cloud of gas and glowing lyen to explain
why there's light inside in 1913
Canadian Marshall Gardner published his
admittedly non-scientific Treatise a
journey to the Earth's interior which
argued that there could be a second
smaller sun inside the earth which is a
possible explanation for the source of
hollow Earth's light and its wonky
physics in the monsterverse of course in
this case the simplest explanation may
be the best some fans think that the
Earth's core provides both gravity and
light to Hollow Earth hey as far as
pseudo science goes it works kind of
rener zawa Apex cybernetics CTO and meca
Godzilla's ill- fated pilot gets a big
introduction in Godzilla versus Kong but
doesn't really seem like much more than
a hired goon in the end why give such a
minor character so much Focus there's
actually a very good reason you wouldn't
catch this unless you all caught up on
your monster verse lore but as Ren's
last name implies he's the son of
Monarch scientist ishiro Cawa ishiro
first appeared in 2014's Godzilla where
he served as an advocate for the big
lizard and returned for 2019s Godzilla
King of the monster ERS in which his
bond with the Titan grew even closer
correctly surmising that Godzilla was
Nature's defense against both the Titans
and environmental ruin Cawa sacrificed
his life to detonate the nuclear bomb
that nursed an injured Godzilla back to
Hell giving the monster the strength he
needed to stop gadora and his reign of
terror in Godzilla versus Kong Kong
looks very different from when we last
saw him in Kong Skull Island basically
he's bigger a whole lot bigger in Skull
Island which takes place in 1973 the ape
is a mere 104 ft tall by 2024 when
Godzilla versus Kong takes place he's
grown to 337 ft according to an official
poster for the movie there's an obvious
reason for the size change in order to
make Kong a credible threat to Godzilla
who stands at a whopping 393 ft Kong
needs to be in at least the same weight
class however there's an in Universe
reason as to why Kong grew over 300% %
bigger too you don't want to wake up the
big one how big is it it's bigger it
wiped out his whole family Kong's the
last of his kind but he's still growing
by the time Godzilla versus Kong rolls
around he's gone through a major growth
spurt and as far as we know we'll keep
getting larger either way this is a
major upgrade for Kong who was only 18
ft tall during the jungle scenes in his
1933 debut feature and 24 ft in the
sequences set in New York City that
makes sense though in the 1933 movie
Kong has to climb the Empire State
Building which stands at 1,250 ft and is
taken out by a handful of biplanes in
Godzilla versus Kong he's knocking over
entire skyscrapers without a second
thought so yeah it's a big difference if
you thought that hey maybe building a
robotic Titan out of one of the most
dangerous kaai you ever was a bad idea
and guess what you were right as
Godzilla versus Kong reveals Mecca
Godzilla was constructed out of two
skulls harvested from Godzilla King of
the monster main villain the
three-headed monster known as both
Monster Zero and gidora one skull is
inside the robot the other houses the
piloting interface that reny rizawa uses
to control Mecha Godzilla and
communicates with a mechanical Titan
using gora's innate psychic abilities at
least that's the plan when Apex injects
meca Godzilla with the hollow Earth
power source Ren loses control of the
Beast the movie doesn't make this
entirely clear so just in case you were
wondering this isn't just meca Godzilla
going Rog In This Moment gidora
Consciousness actually takes over meca
Godzilla's mechanical body bringing him
back to life this makes the following
Godzilla versus meca Godzilla fight much
more personal this is a grudge match
both monsters have personal Stakes
teenage monster hunter Madison
conspiracy theorist Bernie and Madison's
buddy Josh go on a pretty circuitous
Journey while uncovering apex's plans
for meca Godzilla first Bernie downloads
classified information from an apex
Computer Learning that the company is
making many mysterious shipments to Hong
Kong next he sneaks into a restricted
area in apex's Pensacola laboratory
catching a glimpse of an ominous device
during the middle of Godzilla's attack
later Bernie takes Madison and Josh to
see the machine only to discover it's
missing from there the trio get caught
in one of the Hong Kong bound crates
there they learned that the mystery
cargo consists of skull crawler eggs
which are usually only found on Skull
Island once they're in Hong Kong the
unlikely investigators see a live skull
crawler and watch horrified as meca
Godzilla utterly destroys it finally
revealing apex's master plan that's a
very roundabout way to reveal meca
Godzilla and you'd be forgiven for
losing some of the plot along the way
for example what is the thing that
Bernie sees during Godzilla's initial
Onslaught while some fans seem to think
that it's a variation on the Orchid
device used to lure Titans and Godzilla
king of the monsters and Bernie seems to
forget about it entirely once Mecha
Godzilla is revealed it looks like it's
one of meca Godzilla's glowing red eyes
look at the close-up on the eye when
Mecha Godzilla wakes up it's clearly the
same thing Godzilla relies on more than
just brute strength in addition to his
size he has a number of powers including
his iconic Atomic breath that he uses to
decimate his foes and so in order to
give Kong a Fighting Chance Godzilla
versus Kong had to even the odds by
giving the giant primate an axe which
comes with some special abilities of its
own not only is the axe key to unlocking
Hollow Earth's Ultra potent power source
but it can absorb Godzilla's Atomic
breath and dish it back to him however
Godzilla versus Kong only hints at where
the axe came from and doesn't spin much
time explaining how it works for that
you need to turn to a collider interview
with Godzilla versus Kong Ryder and Key
Monster vers contributor Max Borstein
Borstein told the outlet to me it's like
Godzilla's scales have this conductive
radioactive quality and the primate
Kongs had a kind of evolved civilization
of sorts as primates might and simple
tools and had used the spine of a
Godzilla creature to create it so yeah
the axis blades resemblance to
Godzilla's back spikes isn't an accident
the axe is literally made out of the
body of Godzilla's ancestor other than
that borenstein isn't saying much else
about the axe's history although there's
clearly more there to explore director
Adam Wingard told kollider it's
something that we just kind of tease at
in the movie and hopefully we can
explore in later films one of the
coolest moments in Godzilla versus Kong
occurs when Godzilla suddenly alarmed by
Kong's activation of the hollow Earth
energy source fires up up his Atomic
breath and blows a hole to the Center of
the Earth opening a new passage from
Hollow Earth to the surface it's also
unfortunately one of the most confusing
moments how does Godzilla know what Kong
is up to for one and why doesn't the
gravity barrier that may travel between
the two Realms so difficult seem to
apply here the answer to that first
question is implied although not
outright stated in the previous
monsterverse films the first
monsterverse film 2014's Godzilla
establishes that Titans like Godzilla
are drawn to immense power sources
especially nuclear ones when Kong Powers
up the hollow Earth throne room it seems
likely that Godzilla simply detected the
energy surge particularly if his genetic
memory something we know the Titans have
kicked in after all they've probably
encountered the energy before as for the
gravity barrier well there are a few
possible explanations maybe Godzilla's
Atomic breath disrupted the barrier that
separates Hollow Earth from our world
maybe the veil only a supplies to the
hollow Earth tunnel in Antarctica in
Godzilla king of the monsters for
example Monarch's submarine has a much
easier time reaching Godzilla's Hollow
Earth Hideout most likely however is
that the sequence is just awkwardly cut
we see Kong and the hollow Earth
Expeditions heave head into the tunnel
but we don't see most of their time
passing through besides when he emerges
Nathan yells we're about to breach the
veil so it seems like it still happens
it's just not as visually spectacular as
before by that point in the story
there's plenty else to look at after all
Godzilla versus Kong director Adam
winguard promised that the titular brawl
would have a definitive winner and he
didn't lie however some viewers seemed
to think that the movie ended in a draw
it's easy to see how they'd reach that
conclusion like the best superhero team
ups Kong and Godzilla ultimately put
aside their differences and worked
together to take out the bad guy Mecca
Godzilla by the time the credits roll
the two Titans have struck up a
begrudging truce and gone their separate
ways now Godzilla rules over the surface
while Hollow Earth is Kong's domain
before they make an uneasy pece however
the epic Clash has a clear winner
Godzilla there's no doubt about it Kong
and Godzilla battled two times in the
movie once while Kong is in route to
Antarctica and again in Hong Kong the
first fight isn't even close the fight
begins with Kong drugged and Shackled
and takes place in the ocean Godzilla's
home turf Kong doesn't stand a CH the
second fight is more even thanks to the
neutral ground and Kong's axe but
Godzilla still has the upper hand yes
after absorbing Godzilla's Atomic breath
with his axe and delivering a near
knockout blow Nathan says looks like
round two goes to Kong but just a few
minutes later Godzilla is back on his
feet and Kong gets beaten so hard that
his heart begins to stop and the humans
have to jump start the big guy to keep
him from dying face it Kong might be
cinematic royalty but when it comes down
to it Godzilla is the true king of the
monsters nearly 20 years after the final
film in the trilogy some fans are still
scratching their heads over various
elements of the Matrix series so now
we're taking a look at the most
confusing scenes in the franchise and
finally explaining these Matrix moments
The Matrix primarily takes place from
Neo's point of view and in his world
he's just a random guy who happens to be
a really good hacker that all changes
when he's contacted by morphus pulled
out of the Matrix and told he's the one
morphus seems to believe Neo is his man
with absolute certainty but what the
film never tells us is how he knows Neo
is the one the short answer is that it
doesn't matter to the story because
we're meant to experience it from Neo's
perspective as someone coming to terms
with the news that he's a messiah but if
we really want to dig deeper the film
makes it clear through action that
Morpheus in addition to being a leader
of the resistance is an expert hacker
the film also makes it clear that Neo
has gained a reputation as someone who
seems to question the nature of his
reality Neo was also heard of Morpheus
before and has expressed curiosity about
him in the past therefore it's likely
that Morpheus have been observing Neo
for some time before the events of the
film and that he came to the conclusion
that Neo was the man he was looking for
Morpheus did the leg work it's just leg
work we don't get to see on the screen I
can guide you but you must do exactly as
I say in The Matrix Morpheus explains to
Neo that the Matrix exists as a
simulation to occupy the minds of
humanity and make them think that
they're living a normal life in reality
The Matrix exists because the machines
have enslaved all of humanity for the
purposes of power humans are living
batteries kept alive in pods and vast
farming complexes to supply energy to
the machine civilization this of course
begs an important question why don't the
machines try to find other sources of
power as Morpheus also explains in The
Matrix humans scorched the sky during
their war with the machines because at
the time the machines were primarily
dependent on solar power since the
polluted Skies of Earth make it
impossible for the machines to feed on
the sun they use the humans as a new
power Source but what about fossil fuels
or hydroelectric power well the Matrix
takes place at some point in the future
so it's possible the machine simply used
up the remaining fossil fuel as for
water and wind power those could have
been crippled by the permanent loss of
the sun and the change to Earth's
ecosystem even if they weren't though
who's to say the machines haven't tried
those in the past or are still trying
them now the Machine World is vast they
might use more than one power source
after freeing Neo from his pod Morpheus
takes him to meet the Oracle a profit
with a thing for baking cookies and
smoking cigarettes the Oracle spends a
little time alone with Neo before
basically telling him that he's not the
one the thing is Neo is the one that's
established firmly by the end of the
film The Oracle is supposed to know
everything so why does she steer Neo
wrong if you look at the scene again Neo
is actually the one who says the words
I'm not the one sorry
kid you got the gift but it looks like
you're waiting for something shaken by
the news Neo presses her for more
details and that's when the or tells him
about the importance of Morpheus to the
resistance movement she also tells him
how much Morpheus believes in Him to the
point that she's sure one of them will
die as a result this inspires Neo to
stay close to Morpheus and rise to the
occasion of saving his life at the end
of the film putting him on the path of
the one so the Oracle always knew Neo
was the one but she judged him as
someone who wasn't ready to hear that he
needed to have faith in himself first by
telling him what she did the Oracle
pointed Neo in the right direction in
The Matrix franchise a human resistance
movement has forced to live under the
ground with limited resources and
weapons however one of these weapons is
especially effective in the war against
the machines we're talking about a
device that generates an electromagnetic
pulse or EMP that knocks out any
electronic equipment in the vicinity
these devices are used to great effect
this defensive weapons that allow humans
to neutralize nearby machines as a last
resort to live and fight another day so
why don't the humans start using them
offensively well for one emps have
drawbacks they knock out the machines
but they also kill any electronic
equipment the humans are using including
their hovercrafts and computers this
means no one can be jacked into the
Matrix when an EMP is used or they will
die in the process for another there are
simply too many machines to make
offensive use of emps practical their
effect is only temporary and even if
every human hovercraft launched a Full
Assault on the machine city they' barely
reach the outskirts before having to
activate every EMP they had at once to
defeat the first wave of machine
Sentinels another wave would surely
follow and they'd be overrun in the
world of the Matrix Zion is is the last
human City an underground Refuge where
the resistance movement is headquartered
and the human race continues to fight
for survival every resistance mission is
launched from there and hundreds of
thousands of people live in Freedom
while they work to wipe the machines out
entirely meanwhile the machines have
clearly put various systems in place to
counteract human resistance from Agents
to Sentinels and their resources are
vast so why haven't the machines wiped
out Zion as the architect explains and
the Matrix Reloaded Zion is allowed to
Exist by the machines because the
concept of resistance centered around
the prophecy of the one is a machine
creation it was generated to make humans
resisting The Matrix feel like they have
a choice in the eyes of the machine Zion
is a necessary evil that must exist so
the Matrix can persist and their key
source of power can remain in place in
The Matrix Reloaded agent Smith chos an
immense power to copy himself onto
others within the Matrix creating a
sizable Clone Army he then expands that
ability to the real world when he
possesses a resistance member Bane via a
phone line Smith then exists in the real
world through Bane's body but how is
that possible well Smith is a computer
program created by the machines as an
enforcer within the Matrix who's been
freed via Neo's attempt to destroy him
in the first film so in the first movie
Smith is basically an antivirus program
however in the last two movies he
essentially becomes a software virus
himself able to replicate and spread
through contact the humans living in The
Matrix are grown by the machines and
designed to receive software through the
ports built into their flesh Smith is
basically using that same principle to
trans transmit his own code into Bane's
brain possessing him as for how he can
survive in there without a connection
well these humans have certain Tech
built into them that's how the machines
make the illusion of the Matrix persist
and how the resistance does things like
teach themselves martial arts via
software Smith is basically just
hijacking that anate stuff for his own
nefarious purposes in The Matrix
Reloaded Neo meets the architect the
program that designed the Matrix and the
two have a lengthy conversation about
what's going to happen next for many
fans both when the film came out and now
this scene sort of grinds the movie to a
halt after all the architect is a
deliberately humorless analytical being
who speaks well like a computer program
might speak concordant while your first
question may be the most pertinent you
may or may not realize it is also the
most irrelevant so what's the architect
really trying to say it's a little
complicated but it breaks down like this
the resistance movement isn't an
entirely human Creation The Prophecy of
the one was generated by the machines
and the resistance is allowed to persist
because of an anomaly in which a small
percentage of the population rejects The
Matrix as their true reality by allowing
a human resistance movement the
architect can cause correct this by
creating the illusion of choice the one
is also a machine creation and contains
a special code that reboots The Matrix
each time he returns to the source
continuing the cycle of human
subjugation the architect explains this
to Neo and gives him a choice he can go
to the source and be given the
opportunity to repopulate Zion and
restart the cycle or he can save Trinity
and by extension kill the human race Neo
chooses Trinity and his love for her
introduces a new variable that the
architect did not foresee leading to the
next film at the end of The Matrix
Reloaded Neo manifests a new power and
neutralizes several machines with his
mind but he falls into a coma
immediately afterwards at the beginning
of the Matrix Revolutions Neo's body in
the real world is still in a coma but
his Matrix form wakes up in a subway
station where ramachandra and his family
are waiting ramacandra explains that the
train station which they can only leave
on the train man's train is a kind of
limbo it's a waypoint for rogue programs
being smuggled into the matrix by the
Maro vingan to avoid deletion by the
source so how did Neo get there the
Oracle explains on the video game end
the Matrix that when he lashed out at
the machines Neo unwittingly touched the
source but entered limbo rather than
dying that's not the most concrete
explanation ever but at least it
explains why Neo's body and mind were
separated in The Matrix Reloaded The
Oracle explains to Neo that the Matrix
is full of Rogue programs who refuse to
go back to the source for deletion when
they were intended to instead they live
a somewhat hidden life often pursuing
various criminal Enterprises or simply
trying to survive because they like
existing these include the MEO vingan
his twin enforcers the trainman the key
maker and many others at the end of The
Matrix Revolutions The Matrix is
rebooted after Neo fulfills his end of
the bargain with the machines and
defeats Smith by sending him back to the
source so what does that reboot mean for
all of those Rogue programs the short
answer is actually not much while Smith
and traces of him were seemingly deleted
at the end of the film we see the Rogue
program Sati still alive at the exact
moment of the reboot the Matrix online
later reveals that characters like the
MEO vingan are also still alive and
doing their thing in fact the MEO vingan
remains one of the oldest programs on
The Matrix which suggests that he
survived multiple reboots so rebooting
doesn't necessarily mean cleaning up
everything historically it was usually
about the machines trying to repeat the
cycle of human subjugation at the end of
revolutions it signals a fresh start for
human more than it does to Matrix in The
Matrix Revolutions Nia realizes that
agent Smith has become too powerful for
the machines to defeat and so he strikes
to deal with the robotic overlords
offering to take care of Smith once and
for all the machines agree and Neo uses
Smith's obsession with him to launch a
fight he then allows Smith to try to
copy him while he's directly connected
to the source this sends Smith back to
the source where he's deleted and the
Matrix reboots while the machines agree
to Neo's terms of peace with the human
race the downside of this of course is
that Neo gives his life in the process
but the Oracle cast doubt on his
permanent death saying at the very end
of the film that she thinks we might see
him again obviously we know now this is
true because a fourth Matrix film
starring keano Reeves is on the way but
why does the Oracle think this how can
Neo come back from the dead well because
he was pre-programmed to be the one Neo
is partially software even more than the
other humans born in pods so
theoretically a program could be built
from the remnants of his code that
approximates his mind and personality in
fact one of the early story lines in The
Matrix on video game centers on that
idea parts of Neo are out there even if
they're fragmented the trick is bringing
those fragments together as something
that actually retains the essence of
Neo who is cir's Father do all na'vi
speak the same language these Avatar 2
details left a lot of fans
drowning Avatar the way of water starts
with a look at the 13 years of peace
that Jake ntii and the rest of the omaya
clan got to experience after the end of
the first movie The Tribe work works on
repairing some of the destruction the
RDA caused during its tenure on Pandora
while Jake and N tii start a family and
end up raising four children after just
a few minutes of runtime however that
piece is disrupted when humans via the
RDA return to the Moon to some it looks
like the massive spacefaring vessels
that people use to travel the Stars land
on Pandora destroying huge SVS of the
ecosystem in the process what actually
happens is much darker the starships
that Humanity uses to get to Pandora
can't actually land on the surface of
the planet humans need to use smaller
shuttles to get to the ground but when
they return to Pandora they momentarily
dip their larger ships into the moon's
Atmosphere by doing that they're able to
use their engines to burn away the
forest and establish a new mining colony
directly over a large deposit of
unobtanium yeah can we just take this
down a couple of arches spider Who real
name is miles is one of the most
influential new characters in Avatar the
way of water he's just a baby when the
omaya forced the humans to leave Pandora
but there's no safe way for a baby to be
put in cryosleep the baby stays behind
with a few human scientists who remain
on the moon and he grows up with a foot
in Two Worlds while he may physically be
a human spider loves the culture of the
na'vi and he spends a majority of his
time with the Sully children it doesn't
take long for the film to reveal that
spider's father was actually quich from
the first avatar however the film never
explains who spider's mother is fans
might walk out of the theater thinking
that spider's mother left Pandora with
the other humans abandoning her son on
the moon but that isn't the case at all
spider's first introduction to the
Avatar Universe came in the comic The
High Ground where it was revealed that
his mother was a pilot working on
Pandora who died during the fight with
the omaya it turns out that both of his
parents were working to kill the people
who would end up raising their son one
of the biggest surprises in avatar The
Way of water is Steven Lang's return as
quich the aggressively militaristic
leader of the RDA in encampment in the
first movie he happily destroyed home
tree and dreamed of crushing the omaya
completely then he and Jake Sully
squared off and thei ended his life with
a well timed arrow in the way of water
not only is quar back but he's also blue
so how did this happen some point during
the events of the original Avatar the
RDA made a scan of qu's brain his
experience on Pandora was so valuable
that the RDA wanted to preserve it for a
worst case scenario that resulted in
cor's death when the omaya booted the
humans of Pandora the scan got sent back
to Earth there the RDA inserted qu's
memories and personalities into a vat
grown na'vi body so they could send him
back to the Moon with a whole new range
of abilities and available to humans
quich in the way of water is basically a
clone of his former self but there's no
telling what effect his new physiology
will ultimately have on his personality
and views on Pandora early in the movie
the team of na'vi avatars led by Colonel
Miles quich capture spider when Jake
realizes that his old enemy has returned
and that someone who knows all their
secrets has been compromised he
convinces Neri that they need to leave
the omaya to protect their family and
their tribe obviously getting as far
away from quich and the RDA as possible
will help keep the Sully family safe but
it's not exactly clear why Jake thinks
leaving will help the omaya for the time
being the sulles are the rda's top
priority but one way or another all the
na'vi and Pandora are going to have to
fight against a human invasion of course
by the end of the film Jake comes around
to the idea that there's nowhere to run
and decides that he and his family will
once again join the fight let's get it
done the way of water makes some
significant changes to the rda's
original Mission of stealing an
obtainium an immensely powerful energy
source worth of Fortune when humans
return to Pandora they use their ship
engines to burn massive sections of
forest to the ground with plants and
animals out of the way setting up a
mining Depot that can dig up as much
unobtainium as possible possible becomes
a trivial matter now the humans have two
new primary objectives on Pandora First
is the hunting of underwater creatures
called tolken though the tolken are
every bit as intelligent and empathetic
as human beings their brains produce an
oil that's capable of stopping human
aging so the RDA begins hunting them
into Extinction the bigger Mission
however is preparing Pandora to be the
new home for Humanity when Jake and his
family leave their home at aaya they
flee the forest in search of a new home
the Met cayen live along the edge of the
ocean and they spend a majority of their
time underwater swimming along the reef
communicating with creatures like the
tolken and Gathering resources to
survive with green skin and fin-like
appendages the Meena look distinctly
different from the OM teaya and they
have cultural practices that help them
to adapt to life in the water just
breathe breathe despite all the
differences between the two tribes when
the sulles arrive at the Met Cena's home
they have no trouble communicating with
their wouldbe prote ctors how can two
tribes from different parts of the world
with wildly different cultures speak the
same language it might be easy to
consider the shed language a typical
movie cheap moment but there's actually
something more complex going on here all
life on Pandora is linked spiritually
and physically through AA by connecting
themselves to Sacred objects like the
spirit tree the na'vi can commune with
all of Nature and even with their
ancestors it's thanks to This Global
Network that all the na'vi are able to
communicate with each other freely the
tolken hold a special place in me cayena
Society individual me cayena form a kind
of Soul Bond with a tolken that makes a
tolken part of the family from the
trib's perspective while the tolans
spend much of their time in the open
ocean every year they return to the mech
cayena to reconnect with their na'vi
siblings and share stories of everything
that's happened in their time apart from
each other the meenu and the tolken
don't speak the same language but they
do manage to communicate with each other
effectively for the most part the Meena
talk to their soul siblings with a kind
of sign language that lets them form
words while staying underwater the
tolens speak with their own language and
communicate as much as they can through
their actions the fact that the Meen and
the tolken understand each other
probably has a little to do with their
connection through AA it also speaks to
the incredible intelligence of the
tolken and the length of time the two
groups have been connected to each other
Kiri is one of the most mysterious
characters in Avatar the way of water
near the end of the original Avatar Jake
and the omaya attempt to save the life
of Doug Grace Augustine by permanently
transferring her Consciousness into her
Avatar unfortunately Grace doesn't
survive the process but her Avatar
remains physically alive and gives birth
to Kiri sometime after the film ends
Jake and N tii adopt Kiri into their
family in the 13 years between the two
films no one steps forward as kiri's
father Kiri obviously loves being a
member of the Sully family but she still
wonders who her real father could be
while communing with the spirit tree
Kiri gets the opportunity to speak with
Grace his Consciousness she asks about
her father but before Grace can answer
Kiri begins having a seizure severing
her connection to the spirit tree the
story behind K's conception left more
than one fan confused but it's clearly a
mystery that's being set up for a future
movie to explore when Kiri has a seizure
during her visit to the spirit tree she
nearly drowns after that she's
unconscious and in critical condition so
Norman Max arrived at the me cayena
Village via helicopter to treat Kiri
ultimately it's r healing practices that
save Kiri for some unknown reason but
Norm tells Jake about K's seizure and
warns him not to let his adopted
daughter return to the spirit tree
considering that the sulles traveled all
the way to the me cayena Village to
separate themselves from the resistance
fights happening back in the forest it
seems strange that Jake has a way to
communicate with his human friends the
movie doesn't show how he's able to
reach out to Norman Max but it's
possible that his regular wearable com's
device has a range that reaches all the
way back home the helicopter flight to
the Village ends up cluing quish and his
team into the sull location so hopefully
Jake learns to operate a little more
under the radar in the future throughout
the movie Kiri demonstrates a connection
to AWA that goes beyond what the other
na'vi experience Kiri tells Jake that
she can feel AWA around her more than
once Kiri shows off that she's able to
somehow influence the natural life
around her whether through some kind of
telepathic communication or outright
mind control what's especially
interesting is that Kiri doesn't always
influence the plants and animals around
her in the same way when she lies down
in the forest the grass pulses and
ripples outward from her body later in
the me cayena Village Kiri moves her
hands and a school of fish mimics her
but at the movie's climax Kiri needs to
physically connect to a group of plants
before using them to ens snare the
people chasing her one way or another
K's intense connection to AA allows her
to influence the living things in her
environment the exact rules of her
influences are going to have to be SST
outed by another Avatar movie The Wealth
of this world isn't in the ground it's
all around us spider spends most of the
way of water with corich who just so
happens to be the na'vi clone of
spider's real father growing up spider
knew that his dad was a man who
destroyed home tree and killed countless
na'vi so when he meets quich he has no
real interest in spending time with him
quic on the other hand seems almost
immediately pulled towards spider quich
makes spider act as his na'vi
interpreter and all around guide to
Pandora as a trade-off quic won't let
the RDA torture spider for information
about the sulles it might be
understandable if spider becomes
attached to his pseudo father during
their time together but over and over
again spider challenges cit's actions
and tries to get him to stop destroying
lives at the end of the film croit lets
the Sully children get away in order to
save spider's life not long after that
spider sees quit drowning and pulls him
onto land spider might have saved quit
as a way of returning the favor or just
because he like the token is committed
to the idea of not killing but either
way his choice is sure to have
repercussions on the future of the
Avatar
[Music]
story